the left has achieved quite a lot it's
made significant headway just by
manipulating language just by
controlling our vocabulary so a word
like fetus for instance fetus is uh just
latin for offspring that's all that word
means
and so there's no distinction it's a
distinction without a difference a fetus
is a baby why do they insist on saying
fetus though because baby
is a word that uh
carries with its a certain emotional
baggage and you have a certain visceral
reaction when you hear the word baby so
they say well we can't have that we'll
call it a fetus instead it sounds more
medical it sounds more sanitary it
doesn't it sounds less human even the
word abortion itself it is a victory of
the pro-abortion movement that we even
use the word abortion at all abortion is
a word that's supposed to sound again
sanitary medical
abstract but abortion is none of those
things abortion is the killing of an
innocent human being it is murder plain
and simple there's nothing medical about
it